I am telling my Sister Wives that I'm
leaving Cody
so worried this is what you want to talk
about I'm not happy right now I'm not
happy with the situation I mean how do
we unravel something that's been
together for this long Robin Mary and
Janelle Brown emotional about their
sister wife Christine leaving Cody after
25 years I really like living separate I
like my own space I like my own autonomy
I feel like I like me better now in the
teaser for the next Sister Wives Cody
and Christine split shocks the family
how do we unravel something that's been
together for this long there's something
unraveling it's not that easy come on
you guys can we all just get our heads
out of our butts and when it comes to
Cody and Christine's 12 year old
daughter truly Janelle expresses concern
and Cody he wants custody what about
truly I think Julie's gonna be fine
she'll miss everybody of course and it's
going to be hard and taking her from
Cody I can't take her from me
because we'll have to have a shared
custody it'll have to be 50 50. yeah all
that doesn't sit well with Christine
well hell he could have had 50 50 time
with us the whole time we lived here I'm
trying to be a husband a father to their
children a lover to two people who may
not see eye to eye that's a real
challenge
for Cody and Christine telling the other
wives about the end of their marriage
wasn't easy I don't want to burn Bridges
at the end of this some relationships
are going to be fine some are not going
to be fine
I feel unmanly so I'm not going to sit
and go hey somebody's leaving me I don't
want my other wives to see me as weak so
I don't want to talk about it to them
and just months before the split Cody
expressed how hard it was making
multiple marriages work and why divorce
is never an option
I'm not in place where I I say hey to a
wife I'm leaving you that's just never
going to happen
um it's just not you know if if our
relationship isn't good then we either
figure out how to work it out or or
whatever I don't even know what that
looks like we've been doing counseling
for seven years you know yeah so we
don't allow the d word in the house
well not out of my mouth necessarily
[Music]